ja zur nächsten kleinen Rückblick was
ist eine Handlung das ist natürlich eine
recht bare Frage und die muss man genau
spezifizieren ich habe mich jetzt mal so
angenähert eine Verwirklichung unserer
Absichten Intentionen sie werden immer
wieder hier Begriffe finden wie zum
Beispiel Intention die wir noch eine
eigene Sitzung behandeln es wird mich zu
einer allgemeinen Sache viele der
Begriffe die sie eigentlich brauchen um
diese Dinge zu bestimmen die werden sie
erst im Laufe der Vorlesung kennen
lernen wird immer schon ein bisschen was
vorwegnehmen aber ihr ist ganz am Ende
der Vorlesung ergibt sich so ein
Gesamtbild wo sie genau wissen alles
gehört dahin also ich kann eben nicht
von vornherein alle Begriffe gleich
ausführlich erklären sind das müssen wir
eben sukzessive machen und ich habe
versucht die Vorlesung so anzulegen dass
sie eine gewisse Logik hat dass ich also
vom wichtigsten zum speziellen auf dem
allgemeinen zum speziellen vor die also
Intention ist hier wichtiger Punkt also
Absichten muss
bezwecken ist ein Ziel setzen ein Zweck
und wenn ich ein Ziel ein Zweck habe
dann kommt auch immer die Rationalität
ins Spiel dann muss ich schauen wie kann
ich diesen Zweck am besten erreichen
dass das manifestiert sich in der
Handlung den willensbegriff da kommen
auch noch genau zu sprechen und auf den
Begriff der Freiheit der ein sehr
kontroverser Begriff ist weil man mit
guten Gründen auch
bestreiten kann dass wir frei sind und
dann machen wir eine eigene Sitzung dazu
zu diesem Thema inwiefern sind wir
wirklich frei oder nicht das bleibt
jetzt hier einfach nur mal
vorweggenommen dass sie einfach wissen
Freiheit hängt damit auch noch zusammen
wir gehen noch auf das Thema
Handlungsfreiheit und Willensfreiheit
ein das ist ein Thema was zum Beispiel
auch super von der Klausur eignet für
den Typ Nummer 1 die definiert man
Handlungsfreiheit im Gegensatz zu wählen
Frage Typ Nummer 1 gut notieren jetzt
genau also und dann ist die
Willensbildung nötig das heißt der Wille
der liegt nicht einfach so vor Sie haben
in sich verschiedene Strebungen
verschiedene ja Neigungen in sich und um
zu einer Handlung zu kommen müssen sie
ihren Willen erst mal ordnen sie müssen
ihren Willen fokussieren der Wille ist
normalerweise nicht fokussieren deine
Einheit in ihrem Willen bilden erst wenn
Sie die Einheit haben dann haben sie den
Willen so konzentriert dass sie genug
Motivation haben dann zu einer Handlung
überzugehen jetzt habe ich noch einen
anderen wichtigen Begriff den der
deliberation also das Abwägen von
Gründen Gründe werden heute kennenlernen
alles geht darum dass wir verschiedene
Perspektiven ein
es betrifft auch wieder diesen Punkt
sich Einwände zu machen könnte es nicht
auch anders sein eigentlich ist eine
deliberation ein inneres Gespräch mit
sich selbst was spricht dafür was
spricht dagegen sie wegen die Gründe ab
man kann es wie so eine Waagschale
verstehen da gibt es Gründe dafür und
für die andere Schale gibt es Gründe sie
werfen alle Gründe in die Waagschalen am
Ende schauen Sie welche Waage welche
Schale gibt den Ausschlag so kann man
dies ungefähr vorstellen also abwägen
von Gründen
und ich muss natürlich am Ende
entscheiden wo es mich entscheiden ich
kann nicht ewig weitere Gründe in die
waagscheinwerfen und das ist eine
wichtige Frage auf die wir heute
eingehen werden
wieso müsste ich da nicht eigentlich
unendlich häufig die Waagschale abwägen
es gibt da immer wieder neue Gründe
selbst wenn ich das Gefühl habe jetzt
gehen wir mal die Gründe aus dann
schlafe ich meine nach drüber und am
nächsten Morgen habe ich wieder ja und
dann komme ich nie zu einer Handlung das
ist natürlich sehr sehr schlimm wenn
sowas eintreten würde und de facto haben
wir so eine Situation ganz selten es
gibt es Phänomen der willensstrecke das
ist ein ähnliches Phänomen dass wir
einfach nicht wirklich kohärent zu einer
Handlung kommt Thema willenschwäche
behandeln wie eine eigene Sitzung
so und jetzt die ahnen es schon jetzt
möchte ich mit Ihnen Diskussion machen
nämlich zur letzten Sitzung die Frage
sind Unterlassungen Handlung wenn ich
etwas nicht tue tue ich dann doch was
nämlich das nicht tun aber wenn ich doch
nichts tue tue ich doch nicht
ja wir haben eine Umfrage gemacht die
Ergebnisse waren eindeutig die relativ
wirklich die absolute Mehrheit von ihm
sagt das sind Handlungen wir haben
darüber diskutiert was dafür spricht was
dagegen und jetzt meinen zweiten
Rückblick was ist ein Wille und da
möchte ich noch mal auf diesen
Unterschied zwischen unteren und oberen
begehrungsvermögen eigentlich das ist
natürlich auch eine Frage des Typs 1
aber was der Unterschied zwischen
unterem und oben und begehrungsvermögen
warum weil das nämlich eine
traditionelle Unterscheidung ist die ist
in der Geschichte der Philosophie
einfach gibt man spricht vom RB Triumph
brutum und einem abrium lieberum und das
abitrium brutum
da steckt auch brutal drin
auf Französisch Tier brüht also es ist
eher das tierische das Animalische
begehrungsvermögen und das
arbitriumliberum das ist das freie
regierungsvermögen und die werden sich
häufig gegenüber Gesetz
gegenübergestellt allerdings untere
begehungsvermögen traditionellerweise
rechnet man dem zu Betrieben unseren
Neigung und begehrungen das heißt das
ist das begehungsvermögen was wir mit
bloßen Tieren Teilen über die Frage ob
wir vielleicht auch nur bloße Tiere sind
haben wir schon diskutiert in einer der
ersten Sitzungen aber sind wir und da
kamen sie zu keinem ordentlichen
Ergebnis weil da haben wir gesagt 50 50
so wenig hilfreich darüber kann man
leider jetzt nicht mehr reden weil ja
Unentschieden
da geht natürlich verschiedene Argumente
das ist praktisch unsere tierische Seite
die begehrungen Neigungen Triebe
das teilen wir mit der übrigen Tierwelt
aber so die traditionelle Auffassung
weil wir ja natürlich noch die Vernunft
haben
haben wir auch noch ein oberes
legierungsvermögen in uns und das ist
dann der vernünftige reflektierte Wille
also der Wille wir kommen heute noch auf
Harry Frank führt volitionen zweiter
Stufe
also ein Wille der praktisch über sich
selbst reflektieren kann und fragen kann
will ich das überhaupt wollen oder
sollte ich mir nicht doch was anderes
wünschen also dieses untere
begehungsvermögen Winter eine Begehrung
ist dann wird dieser Begehrung
nachgegangen automatisch ja so das
traditionelle Bild das kann natürlich
auch wieder ins Fach gehen Frage stellen
aber das Tier wenn es Hunger hat dann
frisst es etwas dann folgt es seinen
Trieb ich bin der Meinung es gibt Tiere
die machen die reflektieren dafür ja
Delfine bestimmt ja also würde ich
sofort sagen geschenkt ja gibt es noch
viel intelligentere Tiere die haben
bestimmt so ein schwachen Sinnen Opus
begehrungs ja die überlegen sich Moment
aber da gibt es doch noch was und die
haben so eine Umsicht ja aber so im
moralischen Sinne so ein oberes
legierungsvermögen kann man auch als
moralisches begehungsvermögen verstehen
zum Beispiel ich habe jetzt hier einen
Wunsch
aber es ist eigentlich moralisch gut
wenn ich jetzt den Wunsch Folge also
mich selbst zu hinterfragen zu
reflektieren und zwar von einem
moralischen Gesicht
das ist auch typischerweise ein
typischerweise ein oberes
begehungsvertrag ja da gibt es einen
gewissen Spielraum wie Vernunft ist
jetzt nötig damit wir ein oberes
begehungsvermögen haben finde ich die
Antwort liegt häufig drin der
Reflexionen müssen uns unsere Wünsche
und und Absichten reflektieren können
Immanuel krank jetzt gehe ich mal so ein
bisschen auf die Tradition ein wir haben
ja schon Aristoteles gehört Immanuel
Kant behauptet das ist obere
begehrungsvermögen unsere praktische
Vernunft sei also im Grunde genommen ist
unsere bessere Wille unsere Vernunft und
das kann man natürlich in Frage stellen
ist unsere Vernunft ein Wille das hängt
natürlich wieder davon ab was Vernunft
ist wir machen demnächst eine Sitzung
zum Thema von uns praktische von uns ich
komme noch am Ende drauf auf und kann
sagt unsere praktische Vernunft ist eine
moralische Vernunft also die praktische
vernünftig sagt uns was wir tun sollen
formuliert den kategorischen Imperativ
und wenn wir der praktischen Folgen ich
den kategorischen Imperativ beherzigen
dann handeln wir nach unserem oberen
begehrungs
weil dann handeln wir nach moralischen
Zwecken
das kann man natürlich in Frage stellen
kann ich nicht auch ein oberes
begehungsvermögen haben ein Bild
reflektieren ohne das von dem
moralischen Gesichtspunkt auszutun every
Frank wird den wir heute Besen werden
der beatestet um mein Willen zu
reflektieren muss ich nicht ein
moralische Standpunkt einnehmen ich kann
auch andere Gründe haben ich kann fragen
was will ich eigentlich sein worin
besteht meine Identität auch das ist für
Frank wird so ein Ober ein Möglichkeit
den Willen zu reflektieren oder auch
noch andere Formen das wollte ich nur
hier kurz nennen und jetzt stellt sich
die Frage wie können wir unseren Willens
vernünftig bilden und reflektieren so
dass aus einem unteren
begehrungsvermögen als aus dem bloßen
Neigungen trieben wünschen dass wir dein
oberes begehungsvermögen haben also
praktisch Reflexion was ist dazu nötig
und da gehen wir gleich drauf näher ein
ja also das sind wichtige Fragen die den
Willen betreffen und jetzt möchte ich zu
Veranschaulichung dieser Kontroverse wie
man den Willen reflektieren kann was
heißt vernünftiger Wille ist mich auf
ein ganz wichtigen Philosophen der noch
lebt Harry g frankfeld
beziehen der hat ein Aufsatz geschrieben
und den können wir auch mal im Tutorium
behandelt vielleicht so in der nächsten
Sitzung oder können wir Auszüge lesen
ich mache in der Textauszüge zugänglich
mal es wäre eine Idee wenn sie es wollen
ist frei auf Englisch heißt der freedom
of the wheel and the consult of a person
this 1971 erschien der ist also jetzt 50
Jahre alt dieser Aufsatz ja halbes
Jahrhundert muss mir vorstellen und
dennoch ist er total zentral zum Glück
gibt es eine deutsche Übersetzung ich
möchte ihn aber natürlich immer
empfehlen Ihnen im englischen Original
zu lesen weil alle Formen von
Übersetzung Interpretation ist sie
können die Begriffe so oder so übersetzt
also mein Tipp auch gleich zu Beginn im
Studium lesen Sie wenn möglich die Sache
original ja ich habe deswegen auch jetzt
hier im Folgenden deutsche den deutschen
Übersetzungen gebracht uns einfach noch
klarer veranschaulichen zu können aber
man kann es durchaus auch Original lesen
so jetzt sagt Harry Frankfurt folgendes
sie erinnern sich noch an die Frage an
einer der ersten Sitzungen was sind wir
eigentlich
Personen oder Menschen und dann war die
nächste Frage wenn wir Personen sind was
macht uns zur Person und John Lock hat
gesagt unser Selbstbewusstsein macht uns
zur Person das ist ein Angebot auf dem
Markt der Personen
hat ein anderes Angebot der sagt nämlich
dassjenige was uns zu einer Person macht
ist der Wille und ich das
Selbstbewusstsein naja genau genommen
ist es ein reflektierter Wille also das
Selbstbewusstsein kommt wieder ins Spiel
weil es ein will ist der sich über sich
selbst bewusst also eigentlich bringt er
John locks so ein bisschen mit rein aber
er sagt es ist der Wille und jetzt
möchte ich Ihnen einfach mal das Zitat
vorlesen und ich habe die wichtigen
Passagen fett markiert wenn ich nun
behaupte dass das Wesentliche Moment des
personseins nicht in der von Null
sondern Willen liegt so will ich damit
natürlich nicht unterstellen dass ein
Wesen ohne Vernunft eine Person sein
denn allein dank ihrer Vernunft ist eine
Person fähig sich ihres Eigenwillens
kritisch bewusst zu werden und
volitionen zweiter Stufe zu bilden daher
sitzt die willensstruktur einer Person
voraus dass sie ein vernünftiges Wesen
ist also Vernunft zu haben ist sozusagen
die notwendige Bedingung und Person zu
sein brauchen Vernunft als
Reflexionsvermögen aber wir brauchen
noch mehr wir brauchen noch einen wählen
wir müssen die Vernunft auf den Willen
beziehen es muss ein vernünftiger
reflektierte Wille sein die Folien
stelle ich dann auch allen noch
rechtzeitig natürlich auf
Ilias das ist schon mal ganz interessant
und jetzt fällt hier ein ganz wichtiger
Begriff volition zweiter Stufe das ist
natürlich auch eine tolle Frage vom Typ
1 was sind volitionen ja das besprechen
wir jetzt gerade heute
was ist das er sagt jetzt noch ein
bisschen was dazu
noch mal er unterscheidet zwischen
Personen und anderen Kreaturen sie schon
wieder wie soll man es übersetzt
deutsche Übersetzung im deutschen
Kreatur sagt man eigentlich nicht so
gern das man sagt das ist aber eine
komische Kreatur wenn der mir so ein
Tier da aus dem Bodensee kriecht und so
ja also da sehen sie creature
wahrscheinlich creature oder so also ja
da sehen sie da fängt schon an also ich
bin der Ansicht sagte in der Übersetzung
dass ein wesentlich Unterschied zwischen
Personen und anderen Kreaturen in der
Struktur des Willens einer Person zu
finden ist Menschen sind nicht die
einzigen Wesen die Wünsche und Motive
haben oder die wählentscheidungen
Treffen auch Tiere unterscheiden was
wohin sie streben wollen auch das gibt
sie unterscheiden sich darin nicht von
Mitgliedern anderer Arten von denen
einige anscheinend sogar Erwägung
Anstellung Entscheidungen nach
vorhergehender Überlegung treffen es
scheint aber eine besondere
Eigentümlichkeit von Menschen als
Personen zu sein dass sie wie ich sie
nennen werde Wünsche zweiter Stufe zu
fähig sind jetzt haben wir zwei Begriffe
kennengelernt Koalition zweiter Stufe
und Wünsche zweiter Schritt auch die
Frage was sind Wünsche zweiter Stufe ist
natürlich eine Frage die zu Typ 1 der
Fragen gehört ich gehe doch gerade durch
und wir haben dann genug
Diskussionszeit und jetzt sagt Frankfurt
zwischen Wille und bloßem Wunsch dass
das immer schon ein bisschen drauf
gekommen der Begriff des Willens wie ich
ihn Gebrauche ist nicht Umfangs gleich
mit dem Begriff von etwas das den
Handelnden bloß bis zu einem gewissen
gerade geneigt die bestimmter Weise zu
handeln sondern es ist der Begriff eines
effektiven oder handlungswirksamen
Wunsches der eine Person dazu bringt
oder dazu bringen wird oder wurde den
ganzen Weg bis zu einer Handlung zu
gehen das finde ich eine sehr schöne
Allegorie oder tapfer wie auch immer
also sie müssen sich das so vorstellen
sie handeln nicht immer ins zentral
sondern sie müssen einen langen Weg
gehen bis sie zur Handlung kommen also
das ist der willensbildungsprozesse sie
müssen ganz ganz lange
unterwegs sein bis das klappt ja
und ein Wunsch der geschieht mal ganz
schnell zu einem Wunsch ja aber eine
Handlung die braucht einen gewissen Weg
ein Willensbildungsprozess kann man
sagen wenn sie den Prozess durchgeführt
haben dann haben sie ein Willens
Entschluss und dann sind sie ganz ganz
ja entschieden und motiviert wir kommen
noch auf Begriff der Motivation zu
sprechen also wünschen kann ich mir
vieles kann auch verschiedene Wünsche
haben aber die Wünsche sind nicht stark
genug die sind nicht motivational genug
weil wenn sie es wären dann werden sie
wer ist der Wille der zu einer Handlung
führt und jetzt müssen wir unterscheiden
eben zwischen Wunschzeit der Stufe und
volitionen
und jetzt wird es ein bisschen
kompliziert aber er bringt zum Glück ein
Beispiel gleich darauf hin aber ich lese
mal vor jemand hat einen Wunsch zweite
Stufe wenn er entweder einfach einen
bestimmten Wunsch haben möchte oder wenn
er möchte dass ein bestimmter Wunsch
sein will sein
für diesen zweiten Fall also wenn er
möchte dass ein bestimmter Wunsch
geeignet ist sei also handlungswirksam
wird
im zweiten Fall will ich die Wünsche der
zweiten Stufe volition zweite Stufe
nimmt Munition zweite Stufe haben wir
dann wenn es ein praktisch mein Wille
sein soll nicht nur ein Wunsch ich kann
mir verschiedenes wünschen aber das ist
auch mal Bilder werden dann etwas
volition zweite Studium und glaube ich
dass es für das Person sein wesentlich
ist volition zweite Stufe und nicht ganz
allgemein Wünsche zweit
also Personen die müssen immer etwas
wollen die müssen nicht nur sich etwas
wünschen zu wünschen sondern sich etwas
wünschen zu wollen ja es ist logisch
möglich wenn auch unwahrscheinlich dass
ein handelnder wohl wünschen zweiter
Stufe aber keine volition der zweiten
Stunde hat ein solches Wesen wären mein
Augen keine Person als einen triebhaften
jetzt ist hier wieder das Problem der
Übersetzung ich habe deswegen hier
englischen originalbegriff angeben
Wanten wantern bezeichne ich jemanden
der Wünsche erste Stufe hat aber deshalb
keine Person ist weiter gleichgültig und
erwünscht der zweiten Stufe besitzt
keine volition zweite Stufe hatte also
nicht möchte dass irgendein Wunsch sein
Wille werden damit der handlungswirksam
sein das ist jetzt noch alles ziemlich
abstrakt und auch noch ziemlich
unverständlich jetzt muss man wieder wie
ein guter philosoph
oder eine gute Philosophie sich fragen
ja gibt mir doch mal ein Beispiel das
ist doch jetzt alles schön
volition zweiter Stufe Wünsche zweiter
Stufe wie sieht es jetzt konkret aus und
das dürfen Sie auch gerne immer
jederzeit fordern von anderen
Philosophen Philosophen gib mir noch ein
Beispiel 17 konkret aus und es macht
auch Harry friendford weil er eben ein
sehr guter Philosoph ist
und unterscheidet zwischen Personen den
triebhaften also
Unterscheidung zwischen einer Person
einen triebhaften lässt sich am
Unterschied zwischen zwei
Drogensüchtigen bedeutet also er bringt
jetzt ein ganz konkretes Beispiel aus
der Lebenszeit wir wollen annehmen dass
die physiologischen Bedingungen die der
Sucht zugrunde liegen in beiden Fällen
gleich sind dass beides Süchtigen
unausweichlich ihren periodischen
Verlangen nach der Droge erlege
insofern ist es identisch einer von
beiden hasst seine Sucht und kämpft
unablässig verzweifelt aber erfolglos
gegen ihre macht er probiert alles wovon
er meint es könne ihn befähigen sein
Verlangen nach der Probe zu überwinden
aber dieser Wunsch ist zu mächtig er
kann ihn nicht widerstehen und am Ende
bleibt jedes Mal das Verlangen Sieger
über er ist ein Süchtiger Widerwillen
hilflos der Gewalt seiner eigenen
Wünsche
sehr schöne Beschreibung es gibt zum
inneren Konflikt am Ende unserer er
liegt der Drogen sich die jedoch der
sucht aber es ist er war Widerwille also
er will es eigentlich nicht aber er muss
es weil er eben süchtig ist
ja der Süchtige Widerwille von dem wir
jetzt gerade gesprochen haben hat
einander wieder streitende Wünsche der
ersten Stufe er möchte die Drogen nehmen
und er möchte sich doch zugleich davon
zurückhaltend deswegen ist einem inneren
Konflikt über diese Wünsche erster Stufe
hinaus hatte aber noch eine volition
zweite Stufe er steht dem Widerstand
seiner Wünsche die Probe zu nehmen oder
auch von ihr abzulassen nicht neutral
gegen er möchte das der zweite Wunsch
also nicht die Droge zu nehmen und nicht
der Erste sein willensfall das ist laut
Definition eine volition zweiter Stufe
möchte das ein Wunsch mein Wille werden
er möchte dass ich der zweite Wunsch
wirkungsvoll das haben wir gesagt eine
Handlung ist hat was mit
handlungswirksamkeit zu tun wirkungsvoll
Durchsätze und den Zweck abgeben den er
durch das was er wirklich tut zu
erreichen
also ganz interessant er hat da findet
im Kopf ganz viel statt genau gesagt in
Willen des Drogensüchtigen hat wieder
streitende Wünsche er identifiziert sich
mit einem der Wünsche möchte das soll
mein Bild werden aber es gelingt nicht
weil dieser Wunsch nach der Droge zu
stark ist und jetzt unterscheidet
Frankfurt da davon noch den triebhaft
Süchtigen der andere Süchtige der
dieselben Bedingung hat der andere
sichtige ist ein triebhaftes Wesen auch
da ist die Übersetzung wie ich finde
bisschen unglücklich also würden sie ein
Mensch eine drogensüchtige Person
antriebhaftes Wesen bezeichnen ich will
hier nur dafür sensibilisieren einfach
auch bei der Übersetzung über kritisch
hinzuschauen ist ein triebhaftes Wesen
seine Handlungen spiegeln die Ökonomie
seiner Wünsche der ersten Stufe ohne
dass es ihn kümmert ob die Wünsche die
ihn zum Handeln treiben auch Wünsche
sind durch die er sich zum Handeln
veranlasst sehen möchte es gibt Probleme
gibt es Probleme an die Droge
heranzukommen oder sie sich zu
verabreichen dann können seine Reaktion
auf das Verlangen nach der Droge
verschieden Überlegungen einschließen
also instrumentelle Vernunft wie komme
ich am besten zur Droge sozusagen aber
es geschieht in niederseppt ob er auch
möchte dass ich aus dem Verhältnis seine
Wünsche eben der Wille ergibt den er hat
der triebhafte Süchtige kann ein Tier
und deshalb unfähig sein sein will zu
bedenken jedenfalls unterscheidet er
sich was ein triebhafte Unbekümmertheit
angeht nicht von einem Tier
okay da habe ich jetzt gleich natürlich
einige Fragen da haben wir einiges zu
diskutieren aber das ist der Punkt ja es
gibt also den den Süchtigen der es
wieder Willen ist bei dem in Willen eine
Reflexion stattfindet da gibt es eine
Spannung er identifiziert sich nicht mit
dem Wunsch zu Droge er will das der
andere Wunsch nicht die Drucker zu dem
handlungswirksam ist und er die Droge
praktisch links liegen lässt er kann es
aber nicht der Wunsch ist zu stark aber
er hat eine Identifikation mit sein
vorgenommen und zwar will ich und
deswegen hat der volition zweite Stufe
und deswegen ist ein Person obwohl er
drogensüchtig ist der Trieb hat züchtige
der bei dem finden diese Dinge hier gar
nicht statt deswegen sagte sie eine
Unbekümmertheit nicht von einer
Unbekümmertheit die ihn auszeichnet ja
okay jetzt hat es mal veranschaulichen
also er sagt noch was das
charakteristische Merkmal eines
triebhaften eines one-ton ist das ihm
sein willig gleich seine Wünsche Treiben
in bestimmte Dinge zu tun ohne dass man
von ihm sagen könnte er möchte sich von
solchen Wünschen bewegen lassen oder er
Züge es vor von anderen Menschen zum
Handeln veranlasst werden die Klasse der
triebhaften Wesen der onetons wir müssen
uns überlegen gibt es vielleicht eine
bessere Übersetzung von bonton darüber
Disk diskutieren wir gleich schließt
alle Tiere ein die nicht Menschen sind
aber Wünsche haben und alle kleinen
Kinder
gleich gehören sie auch manche wachsen
nämlich eben die triebhaft zu stehen auf
jeden Fall können Erwachsene mehr oder
weniger triebhaft auf Wünsche erste
Studie reagieren Bezug auf die sie keine
volition zweite Stufe haben und jetzt
sagt er noch was wenn ich sage dass es
für Personen charakteristisch ist ihre
eigenen Wünsche und Motive werden zu
beurteilen also die reflektieren auf
unsere Wünsche von einer second
order-volution sozusagen zweite Ebene
wertend da kommt das Thema
normativitäten rein da gehen wir noch
ausführlich drauf ein so will ich damit
nicht unterstellen dass in den
volitionen zweiter Stufe unbedingt eine
moralische Einstellung zum Ausdruck
kommen die jemand gegenüber seinen
Wünschen erster Stufe einnehmen es muss
kein moralischer Standpunkt sein von dem
aus jemand seine Wünsche der ersten
Stufe seiner Beurteilung unterzieht das
ist jetzt wieder die Frage nach dem
oberen begehrungsvermögen musstest obere
begierungsvermögen des reflektierende
regierungsvermögen muss das moralisch
interessiert sein also muss jetzt der
dro Süchtige der wieder will
drogensüchtig ist damit eine Person
genannt werden kann aus moralischen
Gründen jetzt die Droge nicht nehmen
wollen oder kann es einfach auch eine
andere Grund haben der nicht moralisch
ist ein Fremdwort sagt es muss kein
müssen keine moralischen Gründe sein und
es führt uns jetzt auch zum nächsten
Punkt und jetzt müssen wir aber noch
eine kritischen Rückfragen eine peripher
stehen bedeutet es dass triebhafte Wesen
Wanderns da sie keine Personen sind auch
keine würde haben das sagt Frankfurt
nicht aber man könnte doch den
Personenbegriff auch Stellen eng an die
Würde des Menschen finden also wie ist
der moralische Status von wantens wieso
sollten volitionen zweiter Stufe bereits
für eine personale Handlung genügen gibt
sich hier nicht ein infinitarregress zum
Beispiel volition dritter Ordnung oder
dritter Ordnung ja also wieso genügt
nämlich jetzt mit der Handlung zu
identifizieren müsste mich nicht doch
damit noch mal identifizieren und so
weiter und so fort warum genügt es
einmal drauf zu reflektieren auf die
Dusche wo sie nicht auf diesen Wunsch
zweiter Ordnung noch mal von einer
dritten Ordnung reflektieren und so
weiter und so fort es gibt dann einen
unendlichen Regress also wir sind
unendliche und dann komme ich nie zum
Handeln ja also das muss man fragen und
jetzt gehen wir aber noch mal auf die
Diskussion zurück vielleicht haben Sie
sonst noch Fragen dann geht es weiter im
letzten Teil mit dem der Diskussion über
die Gründe
ja Harry Frank wird Theorie ist sehr
einflussreich aber man kann sie auch mit
guten Gründen noch etwas weiter
problematisieren jetzt geht es in der
heutigen Sitzung weiter mit dem Thema
Gründe wir haben immer schon wieder den
Griff des Grundes gehört ich habe einmal
ganz zu Beginn gesagt Gründe sind die
Antwort auf die Frage warum eine Person
etwas getan hat das ist natürlich noch
ziemlich vage und wir müssen jetzt ganz
genauer mit dem Begriff des Grundes
befassen die Antwort auf die Frage warum
jemand etwas getan hat wieder lautet
weil sie erwarten Sie auf die Frage
warum hast du das die Person weil ich
das und das sind das also nicht darum
wenn die Person sagt darum dann haben
wir ein Fall von
willküren wenn die Person aber sagt weil
x weil y bei Z dann sind es die Gründe
die dafür
gesprochen haben wir diskutieren darüber
gleich weiter da gibt es noch viele
diskutieren wir können jetzt dieses weil
diese Begründung da steckt auch der
Grund schon die können wir jetzt in fünf
Bedeutungen Aspekten unterscheiden da
gibt es auch eine große Debatte darüber
aber ich möchte jetzt mal so ein paar
nennen man kann sagen normative Gründe
das sind gute zwingende Gründe für etwas
man kann sogar auch sagen es sind nur
alles
wobei nicht immer moralische Gründe
zwingend sein aber moralische Gründe
nach Kant zumindest nachdem man kann das
Sittengesetz wir kommen nächste Sitzung
auf praktische Vernunft Moral hat eine
Normativität Normativität ist auch noch
ein Thema eine eigene Sitzung eine
Verbindlichkeit da wird etwas gefordert
soll etwas getan werden soll und nicht
nur ein sein
normative und sieht immer es ist ganz
schwierig die verschiedenen Gründe
voneinander abzugrenzen weil das
eigentlich Aspekte eines grundtes sind
sie dürfen sich das nicht vorstellen
dass verschiedene
sind man kann einen Grund so oder so
betrachten aus dieser Perspektive hat
verschiedene Funktionen
motivieren können
ein guter Grund wird sich in der Regel
auch zu einer Handlung motivieren können
der hat die Kraft das sieht dann auch
etwas tun
es gibt auch weniger gute Gründe ja
natürlich sehen Sie sofort damit ein
Grund motivierend sein kann muss
irgendwie
normativ relevant sein das heißt er muss
an mich selbst eine Anforderung stellen
ja muss ein Triebkraft haben das ist die
Normativität aber in dem eben die
Triebkraft des Guten Grundes entfaltet
wird wird er zu einem motivieren
also handlungswirksame Gründe sagt
dann kann man noch das nehme ich jetzt
noch hinzu kausale Gründe und als
Aspekte unterscheiden ja die sind
natürlich ganz ähnlich wie motivierende
Gründe motivierende Gründe müssen
überhaupt kausal relevant sein das heißt
da muss etwas bewirkt werden
wirksame ursächliche Gründe und diese
kausalenkunde kann man natürlich auch im
Kontext von Szenarien sich überlegen wo
wir nicht frei sind wenn wir eben zum
Beispiel süchtig sind auch das kann ein
Grund sein natürlich kein guter Grund
aber auch das Fahren natürlich ein Zwang
kann auch ein Grund sein dadurch kein
handlungsgrund ich kannte ja nicht wenn
ich in einer Zwang und wie geht
zumindest nicht im Freien Sinne Freiheit
aber wenn man fragen warum ist das
passiert nicht nur angewendet auf
Handlung ist und warum ist das passiert
dann kann man sagen weil mein kausalen
es gibt immer motivierenden und auch
noch ein kausalen Aspekt der
verwirklichen hervorbringen oder gibt es
noch rationale ich möchte das mal nennen
das hängt natürlich auch ganz eng mit
dem zweiten Grund zusammen rationale
Gründe sind Gründe die aus einem Schluss
erfolgt als sie erwegen verschiedenes
und kommen dann zu einem Urteil am
Schluss und dann ist auch das ein Grund
weil eben es am rationalsten ist das zu
tun als rationale Gründe
begründen da steckt es ja auch schon den
begründe doch das mal da muss man
Argumentation bringen und dann gibt es
noch
das habe ich dann aus diesem Handbuch
über praktisches Philosophie das stelle
ich auch noch rein Auszügen in ILIAS den
Punkt explikative Gründe die hängen
natürlich auch ganz eng mit rationalen
explikative Gründe die rechtfertigen
eine Hand das hängt natürlich auch ganz
eng zusammen mit dem Fall gibt man eine
Begründung ab rechtfertig gemacht
weil da muss man das explizieren also
erklären und also das sind jetzt so
verschiedene Aspekte von Gründen darum
geht es mir dass sie den Grund den
Begriff des Grundes mein verschiedener
Hinsicht sich mal genauer betrachten
können am wichtigsten und das sage ich
Ihnen jetzt auch für die Klausur dass
sie nur das Wissen am wichtigsten ist
natürlich den normative Grund und der
motiviert
das sind besonders wichtige Aspekte von
Gründen wir wollen das jetzt mal kurz
diskutieren nämlich
inwiefern sind Gründe normativ und
verbindlich wie kann man sich das
konkret vorstellen müssen gute Gründe
immer moralische Gründe zahlen wenn ich
schon so fragt natürlich nein oder
vielleicht doch
sind Gründe relativ ja also es zieht
dann sich wieder auf diese Normativität
an für die eine Person Grund an normativ
sein und für die andere Person und nicht
normativ ja von was hängt es ab ob die
Gründe normativ sind oder relativ sind
können wir auch gegen unsere besten
Gründe Handlung Handeln ja wenn wir also
wirklich extrem gute Gründe haben die
entsprechend können wir dann auch
dagegen handeln wie ist das zu denken
was ist der Unterschied ist nur noch zu
allen bringen zwischen inklinierenden
und Netze zitieren ich sage nur dass sie
mal diese Wörter gehört haben
imklinierend heißt geneigt machen eine
Inklination ist eine Neigung einen
eigenen hinneigender Kunde macht nichts
etwas geneigt der legten etwas nein und
nicht sie zitierende Gründe da steckt
die netzhesitas drin die Notwendigkeit
wenn mich etwas zwingt dann ist es
natürlich auch ein Grund für etwas ja
aber die ist sehr unterschiedlich genau
zu verstehen darüber möchte ich jetzt
ganz kurz noch ein bisschen diskutieren
wir müssen nicht über alles diskutieren
aber ein bisschen
also wir sehen wir können über Gründe
Treffen nicht streiten wichtig ist man
dass man verschiedene Aspekte von
Gründen auseinander hält dass man da
differenziert Rücken spricht ja das ist
auch so ein Typ für Frage 1 ja welche
verschiedenen Aspekte von Gründen gibt
es ja
den nächsten Sitzung behandeln wir die
Frage was ist praktische Vernunft der
vernünftbegriff ist schon immer wieder
gefallen every Frank wird hat ihn auch
gefragt ja er hat gesagt Vernunft ist
nötig damit wir überhaupt unser will
bilden können aber unser Wesen unser
personales Wesen liegt nicht in der
Vernunft sondern und zum Wille der von
uns voraussetzt aber der nicht in der
Vernunft aufgeht und sehnen sich noch
Manuel kant hatte gesagt umso oberes
begehrungsvermögen ist die praktische
von uns ja ist jetzt der Wille dasselbe
wie die Vernunft diese Frage wird man
nächsten Sitzung diskutieren dann werden
wir unterscheiden wie unterscheiden sich
theoretische von praktischer Vernunft
die reden hier natürlich von praktischer
praktisches vernünftig unser damit
betrifft theoretische Vernunft haben Sie
eine Idee auch wir müssen es gerade noch
Zeichen ja gerade noch auf ich gehe
deswegen selbst drauf ein theoretisches
Vernunft ist eben die Vernunft die nicht
direkt unser Handeln betrifft ja wenn
Sie zum Beispiel Erkenntnis versuchen zu
erlangen wenn Sie fragen was kann ich
wissen ja was ist der Grund dafür auch
wenn sie Mathematik betreiben wenn sie
logische Schlüsse ziehen dann ist es die
theoretische wenn sie nach der Frage
Streben was kann ich wissen
wenn sie nach der Frage Streben was soll
ich tun dann müssen Sie die praktische
Vernunft sozusagen aktivieren und jetzt
stellt sich die Frage ja wie wie
unterscheiden sich theoretisch und
praktische Vernunft und sind es
verschiedene Vonn wünschte oder wie man
es nennen kann haben wir in uns zwei
Vernunft fünf vernünftig oder haben wir
eine von uns eine einheitliche Finanz
ein Vermögen der vernünftiger
Rationalität und das ist nur in der
Anwendung verschieden also wir können
unsere auf unser Handeln beziehen und
auf unserer Canon beziehen wenn Sie
genau nachdenken wenn sie sehen
natürlich muss ja auch die theoretische
von irgendwie betätigen wenn ich handeln
will muss natürlich auch Schlüssel
ziehen weil die vielleicht nicht direkt
jetzt aufs Handel gezogen sind und noch
eine ganz wichtige Unterscheidung die
jetzt mir die praktische Vernunft
betrifft ist die Unterscheidung zwischen
instrumenteller und moralischer oder
instrumenteller und kategorische
absolute
das bezieht sich wieder auch Immanuel
Kant Immanuel Kant hat auf den werden
wir nächste zu sprechen kommt zwischen
hypothetischen und kategorischen
imperativen
Unterschieden hypothetische imperative
sind imperative die nur unter einer
bestimmten Bedingung Geltung haben
Imperativ ist ein Befehl also normativ
ne ein sollenz Anspruch hypothetisch
Imperativ wir haben nur dann ein
zollensanspruch wenn nicht ein
bestimmtes Ziel erreichen also wenn ich
jetzt
etwas mit kaufen möchte zu essen dann
mache ich am besten das dann gehe ich
jetzt runter zu Cafeteria und und kaufe
das dann dieser Imperativ jetzt zu
Cafeteria zu gehen der geht der geht
natürlich nur unter bitte Bedingung dass
ich Hunger habe wenn ich keinen Hunger
habe gibt es kein Imperativ der mir sagt
wo ich hingehen soll um den Hunger zu
befriedigen dann hat er keine Bedeutung
mehr anders ist es mit kategorischen
imperativen die Geld nachkannt wieder
Begriff schon sagt unbedingt in jeder
Situation ob ich jetzt Hunger habe oder
mich
der kategorische Imperativ gilt in jeder
Situation weil er ein moralischer
Imperativ ist nach Kanz sollen wir in
jeder Situation nach moralischen Gründen
handeln also handmacht die moralischen
Gründe die normativen Gründe sehr stark
sind der moralische Gründen eigentlich
sollte für all unsere Hand immer unter
moralischen Gesichtspunkten kann nur
dann sind wir eigentlich freiwillig und
das kann man natürlich auch sehr
treffend problematisieren weil wie sieht
es denn aus wenn du unmoralisch hat sind
wir da auch noch frei gewesen vernünftig
gewesen das interessiert mich diese
Frage ist hier ich kann doch auch im
unmoralischen Handeln sehr intelligent
sein Denken sie machen das perfekte
Verbrechen ja also eine perfekte Person
die ein perfekter Verbrecher der
perfekte Verbrecherin die die strengt
ihre Vernunft an ja all die muss
ziemlich viel nachdenken um zum Eindruck
zu kommen oder was können Sie jetzt
selbst ausdenken sie ist auch frei darin
und sie ist auch verantwortlich für die
Partner wenn sie ertappt wird wird sie
zurecht vor uns Gericht gestellt und
eingesperrt
also wie sieht es damit aus wir sind
Fragen die wir in der nächsten Sitzung
diskutieren wollen wir haben jetzt noch
ganz kurz Zeit ein paar Fragen zu
behandeln die das nächste Sitzung
betreffen